Play that game with me, man. Please.
Don't play that game with me. But if you
want in one section, can you go to
Isaiah 63? All three in one place. One
place, all three. Go to Isaiah 63.
You I you asked me for one place, okay?
Go to Isaiah 63. When you get there, let
me know.
When you get to Isaiah 63, I want you to
read verses 7 to 8 to start with.
I will recount [clears throat]
the kind acts of the Lord, the praises
of the Lord, and for it the Lord has
wrought for us.
>> Little louder, brother. Little louder.
I will recount the acts of the Lord, the
praises of the Lord, and all that the
Lord has wrought for us. The vast
bounties to the house of the trial, that
he bestowed upon them according to his
mercy and his great kindness.
Okay, so you read Isaiah 63:7-8, right?
Uh yeah. Okay, now read verse 9 slowly.
Uh in all their troubles, he In all
their troubles, he was troubled.
And the angel of his presence delivered
them.
In his love
>> Then who delivered them? Wait. Who
delivered them?
The angel of his presence delivered
>> Okay, count. The angel of his presence.
The angel of his face did what for
Israel?
Delivered them. Who delivered them?
The angel of his presence.
>> Okay, good. So, the angel of God's face
delivered them. Keep going. Now, when
you finish that, go all the way to 10.
All the way to 10 please. Little louder
so we can hear you.
All right.
Uh
>> He himself redeemed them, raised them,
and exalted them all the days of old.
But they rebelled and grieved his holy
spirit.
>> No, stop. Hold on. Before you move on,
count for me because I'm not very good
at math. In Isaiah 63:9,
it says what again? Slowly, because I'm
not good at math. You're going to help
me at math.
Read Isaiah 63:9 one more time.
In all their troubles, he was troubled.
Who was troubled? Who's the he? Hold on
before because we got to break it down.
Who's he?
He was troubled. Who's he?
Hashem. Okay, Hashem, God. And then read
slowly.
>> [clears throat]
>> You're in verse nine. Just read nine,
man. Don't lose your place. Stay there.
>> troubles, he was troubled and the angel
of his presence Okay, angel of his
presence did what?
>> [clears throat]
>> Deli- Hold on. The angel of his presence
delivered them. Okay, the angel of his
presence saved his people. Okay, keep
going now. Read all the way to 10.
In his love and in his pity, he himself
redeemed them, raised them, and exalted
them all the days of old.
But they rebelled and grieved his holy
spirit.
>> Three. Count with me.
Hashem, the angel of his presence, and
his holy spirit. Can you count cuz I'm
not that smart. I'm very stupid in math.
Hashem,
hold on. Hashem,
the angel of his presence, and his holy
spirit. How many is that?
Three.
Say it again.
Three. Do you see a fourth?
Is there a fifth? Is there a sixth or
only three?
I mean,
yeah, there's fourth. Where? Show me the
fourth. I'll give you $10 million if you
show me a fourth.
Surely you are our father and the
Abraham of And who's our father? Hashem,
right?
Yeah. So, okay. Hashem the father,
the angel of his face and his Holy
Spirit. Man, what do we Christians
believe? Well, hold on. What do we
Christians believe? God the father,
Jesus the father's son who's his
messenger and the Holy Spirit.
You are our father, Hashem, and the
angel of your presence saved us, and we
rebelled and grieved your Holy Spirit.
Hmm, and that's Isaiah 63. Wow, wonder
of wonders.
Yeah, yeah. Yeah. So, where's the
fourth?
I don't know. I don't Do you have a
>> no fourth. That's my point. I don't
know. I don't I I
When I read this, I'm assuming they're
all the same God cuz We Of course
they're the same God, but are they the
same person?
Yeah. Oh, so it's God who speaks to
himself as the angel who then sends
himself as a spirit?
Wait, what? Yeah. Yeah, okay. All right.
Then go to Zechariah, chapter 1.
Okay, what's what's in there, dude? I
don't even know where that is. That's
near the end of your Tanakh. Open it up
find it. It's in your Tanakh. These are
all your books. I didn't even quote New
Testament. Bro, I've only read up to
Kings 2, dude. Second
>> It's okay, dude. You don't need to read
up to Just find Open your Bible, table
of contents.
Say it again. Yes, dude, you need to
read the whole thing from page to page.
Okay, that's fine. You can then go back
and read page to page to see where I'm
wrong, but before you do that, go to
Zechariah chapter 1 in your Tanakh. Open
up your Tanakh.
Okay? Your table of contents is going to
tell you the Nevi'im, the Nevi'im
or Nevi'im. It's in the prophets. Cuz
you break it down, Torah, Ketuvim, it's
Nevi'im, Ketuvim. Look for Nevi'im.
Nevi'im, the prophets, you're going to
see Zechariah.
And when you get there, let me know.
All right.
Let me know.
Yeah, I'm there.
Okay, when you're chapter 1, Zechariah
1,
you're in chapter 1, read 12 to 14 for
me. Is this really how you justify your
ideology? Uh forget about me, man. I'm
quoting your book to you justify your
belief. Forget me. I'm just quoting your
book. Forget me. I'm an atheist and I'm
just reading your book and I want you to
explain hey, your Tanakh, what's going
on here? Explain it to me.
So don't play that game with me. Forget
me. I I have not yet quote a single
New Testament book, let alone quoting
your rabbis. I got quotations of your
rabbis lined up for you. I didn't even
go there yet. Um I I feel like the thing
about Torah is that it kind of explains
the world. It sign explains what?
It explains the world. So from my
perspective, if Yeshua the Nazarene was
really God, it would say that in the
Torah.
>> It say with what again? Nazarene what?
If Yeshua the Nazarene was really God, I
feel like it would say it in the Torah
like very specifically. You mean you're
looking for the word Yeshua?
The name? I mean that that's who like
Never mind. Let's just go to the
Zechariah.
>> No, cuz we can show you Yeshua because
if you're asking me for the name, you're
asking too much because not even
>> asking for it should say specifically.
It should say but I will show you it
says specifically.
Why are you getting animated? I can GET
ANIMATED TOO. YEAH, IT DOES SAY THAT
OVER AND OVER AGAIN. ISAIAH 9, JEREMIAH
[screaming] 23, DANIEL 7. I'LL GET
THERE. IT DOESN'T SAY YESHUA.
My friend, don't be that silly because
if I play that game, okay, oh wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, let's play your
game. Let's play your game. Don't change
the subject. Listen, now you're arguing,
you're not listening.
If you're going to play that game that
the word itself has to appear,
you know you're going to get embarrassed
because even the passages that your
rabbi says about Mashiach, the word
Mashiach is not used.
You mean it's not used? Can you show me
in your Tanakh
a prophecy that uses the word Mashiach,
Mashiach ben David? Show me those name
names in those prophecies. I don't read
Hebrew, I can't do that. You can't
because it's not there. I'm letting you
know, go ask Tovia Singer, say, "Hey
Tovia, so you're talking over me again."
You're talking over me, you're not
listening. Listen so you can learn. Go
to Tovia Singer
and tell Tovia, "Tovia, when you say
this prophecy is about Mashiach, does
the word Mashiach appear?" He'll say,
"No."
"Okay, how do you know it's about
Mashiach?" Because what it says about
this figure can only be about Mashiach.
So, don't play the game that I got to
show you the word.
Well, I feel like that's how it should
be because Okay, then that means you
shouldn't be a Jew because the Tovia
Singer said, "Well, we don't feel that
way."
No, but it says in the Torah to only
worship me and don't worship any other
Really? Oh, wait, wait, wait, so if I
show you they worship the angel, what
are you going to tell me?
Uh that sounds like idolatry to me.
>> Oh, you sure? Worshiping the angel is
idolatry?
Uh
it sounds like idolatry. Okay.
Read for Zechariah 1 and I'm going to
show you where they worship the angel.
Zechariah 1.
You're in chapter 1, read 12 to 14.
Zechariah 1 verses 12 to 14.
Thereupon the angel of the Lord
exclaimed, "Oh Lord of hosts, how long
will you
>> Okay, the The of the Lord is talking to
who?
Uh
I don't know who he's talking to.
>> Read it again. It's right there. He just
told you. He's just talking right there
in front of you. It says who he's
talking to.
Thereupon the angel of the Lord
explained, "Oh Lord of hosts, how long
Oh Lord of hosts. So who's he talking
to?
I don't know.
God, I guess. Yeah, you guess? There's
no other Lord of hosts but God.
>> know, dude. This is I've never
>> Okay. All right. All right, well, here.
Just read it. Okay. Calm down. It's all
right. The angel is speaking to the Lord
of hosts. I know that it's hard. I'm
just saying that's you now. I never
>> the angel, I get it. The angel is
speaking to the Lord of hosts. The only
one who's the Lord of hosts is Hashem.
So the angel of the Lord says to Hashem,
the Lord of hosts, what? Read it.
Uh
Then the angel who talked with me said
to me, "Proclaim, thus said the Lord of
hosts, I'm very zealous for Jerusalem
for Zion, and I am very
>> 12 and 13. Read 12 to 14. You skipped
12, 13, and 14.
Thereupon the angel of the Lord
explained, "Oh Lord of hosts, how long
will you withhold pardon from Jerusalem
and the towns of Judah, which you placed
under a curse 70 years ago?"
The Lord replied with kind
>> So the Lord, Hashem, replied to the
angel. Pay attention, 13. The Lord,
Hashem, replied to the angel. And what
did he say to the angel?
Mhm.
Uh
Then the angel who talked with me said
to me, "Proclaim, Yeah, read 13 again
slowly because you didn't You skipped
the The Lord answered the angel. Read
13.
The Lord replied with kind comforting
words to the angel who talked
Okay. talked with me. So now pay
attention to 13 before you go to 14. The
Lord answered the angel with kind and
comforting words. So, the angel spoke to
Hashem Hashem replied back. You see that
in 13?
Uh no, I think this is the prophet,
right?
>> No, the angel's not the prophet. Read it
again. It says angel in front of you.
It's there in verse 13, dude.
The Lord answered the angel, not the
prophet.
Uh
Read it, 13.
Right there, Zechariah 1:13, dude.
>> start at 13. How can we just start at
chapter 1? Dude, if you want to read all
14 chapters, I'll read it.
Just read 13. Who is answering who?
I honestly can't. Little louder, I can't
hear you. I don't know if it's Zechariah
or I don't know if it's
>> Brother, do you see in front of your
eyes the Lord answered the angel?
Who talked to me? Yes. So, who's he
answering? Me or the angel? Don't play
games with me. It's right there. I don't
The Lord replied To who?
with kind comforting words.
>> To who?
To the angel who talked with me. Okay,
so he's saying to the angel, hold your
horses,
that angel who's talking to Zechariah
and telling Zechariah what the Lord
said. Don't play games, dude. You can
read Your reading comprehension is good.
So, don't try now.
>> I said? Say it again.
Isn't that what I said? No, you said You
don't No, no, no, no. This is what you
said. No, dude, please. Stop debating.
This is what you said. You said, "I
don't know if it's talking to the
prophet or the angel." No, you do know
because it says the Lord answered the
angel. What angel? The angel that was
talking to me. It didn't say the Lord
said to me. Okay, but who is me?
Dude, don't play games with me, man. I'm
asking a question.
>> Okay, is the Lord speaking to the angel
and the angel speaking to the Lord.
>> with kind words. Is the Lord speaking to
the angel and is the angel speaking to
the Lord?
Okay, yeah. Say it again.
Yeah, the angel's talking to the Lord.
And the Lord is speaking to the angel
and the angel speaking to the Lord,
right?
Yes. Okay, good. Now we established
that.
But didn't you just tell me the angel of
the Lord is God appearing as an angel
sending himself?
Uh no. So here is it God appearing as an
angel speaking to himself again?
Yeah. Oh, so you're admitting
God is appearing as an angel and in that
angel he's speaking to himself. So God
is having a conversation with himself.
Mhm. Okay. Well, I don't know what to
tell you. If that's not a schizophrenic
God, I don't know what it is. So but
that's your problem.